la première décision c'est que le fonds
de solidarité sera supprimé au 30
septembre de cette année
à partir du 30 septembre cette année le
fonds de solidarité sera supprimé je
rappelle que les chiffres sont aussi
très clair il y avait cinq cent mille
demandes de indemnisation au titre du
fonds de solidarité en mai dernier on
est passé à 50 milles au mois de juillet
soit 10 fois moins tout simplement parce
que le retour à la normale se marquent
aussi dans des moindres demandes du
front sud ait cette transition de 1 mois
pour la disparition du fonds de
solidarité
s'accompagnera d'une indemnisation à
hauteur de 20% de la perte du chiffre
d'affaires donc le fonds de solidarité
étant supprimée au 30 septembre jusqu'au
30 septembre nous maintiendrons les
mêmes chiffres d'indemnisation que ce
qui avait été retenu au mois d'août
c'est à dire 20 % de perte de chiffre
d'affaires je rappel nous avions fait
quelque chose de progressif 40 % de
pertes au mois de juin pour
l'indemnisation 30% d'indemnisation de
perdre des chiffres d'affaires au mois
de juillet et 20% d'indemnisation de
perte de chiffre d'affaires au mois
d'août c'est ce chiffre-là qui sera
reconduit pour le mois de septembre
avant l'extinction définitive du fonds
de solidarité au 30 septembre 2021
nous ajouterons néanmoins une condition
pour avoir accès au fonds solidarité qui
n'existait pas auparavant il faut
désormais faire 15 % de chiffre
d'affaires minimal pour avoir accès à ce
fonds solidarité jusqu'au 30 septembre
de cette année pourquoi un poison très
simple c'est qu'il ya des effets
d'aubaine et qu'il y à certaines
entreprises qui plutôt que de rouvrir ce
débat on préfère rester fermés et touché
le fond de solidarité je ne veux pas
d'effet d'aubaine dans l'aide apportée
par l'état c'est à dire par le
contribuable français aux entreprises en
difficulté par conséquent pour avoir
accès aux fonds de solidarité dans les
conditions que j'ai indiquées il faudra
avoir fait désormais au minimum 15 % de
chiffre d'affaires une précision très
important le front solidarité donc
supprimés au 30 septembre
néanmoins l'intégralité des dispositifs
de soutien sera maintenue pour les
départements d'outre-mer qui sont encore
soumis à des obligations de fermeture et
je veux dire à tous nos compatriotes des
départements des territoires d'outre-mer
qui peuvent compter sur le soutien de
l'état et qu'à partir du moment où ils
sont les seuls à continuer à être soumis
à des obligations de fermeture
administrative
ils continueront à bénéficier de
l'intégralité des dispositifs de soutien
prévues par l'état c'est un point qui
est évidemment tout à fait essentiel